alors j'ai quelques photos de certains
chroniqueurs au ski voilà parce que
quand même balle a alors regardé on a en
a qui osent qui a les alésiens ils sont
en train de les trouver mais tu aimes
été changé est elle toujours fraîche ans
ouais bon jour pour être le plus chaud
elle seule elle cherche pas que des
raclettes à la dette a progressé avec
une hausse à l'annoncé
c'est quoi ça un accident que j'ai eu
oui j'étais dans une dameuse leçons avec
plane pour passer un truc de dingue je
me suis cognée contre
enfin la porte s'est ouverte la dameuse
s'est arrêté net on était en dedans et
j'ai explosé mon front en direct l
capsule nescafé la soirée vers ces
horribles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'ail est toujours un des films projetés
serait en train d'y être nous aussi
comme normal non ce qu'il ya en se
cachant rousson qui sait ce qu'est la
toussuire dans l axe qui entre la france
et l'italie
ouais voilà je fais une raquette et puis
ça je mange des macaronis comme floue ce
à quoi mène de san bernardo à la rosière
san bernardo 1
ah bah voilà est bon alors 2 à l'aller
et là on revient en france
là on les lui a longtemps cela on est
bien les français qu'on laisse couler
mais voilà quoi c'est et d'amis quoi
tunisie là on est entouré d'animaux mais
vous alors by naim
je ne vais pas trahir un secret qui a
déjà pécho son moniteur à noter ce n'est
pas parce que je définis le film démarre
à part le fameux ce fameux syndrome du
moniteur de ski est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer le syndrome du moniteur
de ski et ben en fait quand j'étais
petit je tombais systématiquement
amoureuse de mai moniteur de ski bah oui
et donc j'ai cru que la vie c'était
suivre un beau mec en rouge qui vous
fait des blagues tout le temps qui vous
relève quand vous tombez qui est gentil
avec vous mais c'est vrai que ça
rapproche moutier nous relève et et une
fois adulte mais je me suis rendu compte
que c'était pas du tout le cas et que
donc la vie était atroce sur un petit
niveau ce qui nous a un petit goût ou
pas vous êtes petit niveau un petit
niveau
vous vous êtes déjà sortie avec votre
moniteur de ski tout à fait un nom
pareil avec des moustaches faites vous
plaisir donc vous benhaim on sait que
vous êtes sorti avec un moniteur de ski
a tu balances comme ça il se balance
n'est pas david au canada et c'était il
était pas canadiens étaient ils étaient
new york et de newton yout oui mais ils
avaient détruit d'érable ici il a vu
s'éroder râble voilà il était il était
américain et il venait perfectionner son
français et en même temps comme il
savait ce qui est voilà il faisait 1 2
en 1 et
et il avait 23 ans et moi j'en avais 10
18 dans elle s'appelait david nom et il
s'appelait m'aviez dit oui david alors
et new jersey alors là bas j'ai voyagé à
savoir justesse que vous l'avez juste
galoche
ou est ce qu'il ya eu un peu la personne
c'est juste lente et bâtons oui à moi du
mois on était amis estoniens alors te
connaissant là je vois te tais je pense
que l'américain grassi benhaim dit la
vérité
on s'est découvert une âme à kent
huskins tu sais que je suis choqué et
soyez pour moi benhaim c'est comme ma
soeur enfin non mais c'est aux femmes à
beinheim j'appréhende benhaim fait des
faits des coûts faut ni de son corps
alors vous lui excuse moi il est libre
at il dit
elle va découvrir alors vous allez nous
raconter votre histoire
et côté jardin en exclusivité un extrait
où vous parlez des relations entre les
vacanciers et les preuves de ce qu'ils
regardent et des enfants dans le groupe
de thierry oui wind shear et ça va ça se
passe bien oui contente
moi aussi entre 6 et 11 ans j'ai des
expériences avec des moniteurs
fantastique c'est vrai que sur le moment
c'est formidable il n'y a plus de
barrières on se rend pas compte à quel
point c mais bon après
une fois du ton des chambres sacrément
donc au faire attention quand même
les moniteurs de ski sa mi temps relève
la combinaison rouge a plus personne
une personne moi bruno va 15h30 à
courchevel vous parler d'un truc
sexuelle c'est pas du tout sexy
alors moi je suis moniteur de ski pour
les enfants n'ont pas du tout c'était
pour des jeunes enfants voilà que voilà
et un jour chez g si j'ai perdu un
enfant enfermé mais j'aurais dû faire
toutes les exactions ils se sont
inspirés de moi c'est pas bien mais
comment vous avez perdu un enfant
non mais je sais pas je les ai comptés
j'étais comme ça je puis voilà puis deux
flancs bon je vais vous dire la vérité
en fait il y avait deux jumelles dans la
station frites l egypte l c'est en
combinaison jaune et en fait j'ai
cherché parce que pouvoir un peu comme
elle ce qui est donc j'avais tous les
enfants est en fait malencontreusement
un moment d'inattention j'ai perdu un
enfant qui est donc les retrouver je
vais retrouver
voilà un an après l'arrivée
l'enfant va très bien mais voilà
aujourd'hui il va très bien pour draguer
vous avez perdu un an sinon non pas du
tout je croyais pas du tout non je suis
pas là dedans
alors oui l'anecdote est cocasse quand
j'ai commencé à me kassoum les navettes
je suis plus qu'impatient alors j'aime
pas faire la queue au téléski tout ça
quand j'ai commencé à gagner un peu plus
d'argent ce que je faisais
jallet esf et je prenais un prof non pas
je trouve que je skie très bien je suis
désolé de le dire
ces plages de vermeil samoa de vermeil
coiffe etc ou flash de vermeil chamade
vermeil pardon dupeux a laissé bien et
bien sûr qu'ils jugent chamois d'or et
donc de quoi se prennent à un prof en
faites pas pour qu'il m'apprenne mais
pour passer dans l'est que deux
grasset dans les duels et une fois
fasciné dans les yeux comme dallas je
repère une bombe non non moi j'avais 30
ans genre blond 25-26 magnifique
ouais et je dis je veux cours avec
monsieur nom et la fille me dit cette
semaine il fait que les trois étoiles à
gilly a rien d'autre rien d'autre à
d'autres non tout cas les trois étoiles
donc j'ai fait une semaine entière
inquiète rodez avec les trois étoiles où
il était simple donc chasse-neige chasse
neige on descendait vers mes toiles ont
fait pas abbassi troisième étoile mon
sauveur en rue du château flocons donne
moi des leçons à la voilà voilà
j'ai travaillé j'ai dragouiller je ne
dirai jamais son nom car il était il est
hétéro et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
parlé et le 6e jours sur sept on a
conclu non oui alors bat jusqu'au bout
au bout en bout à bout ça veut dire quoi
il a peur de stalactites ou pas phase 2
2 c'est terminé on cherchait ce haut
c'est bon ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est la seule émission où tu as mais
qu'il a une tête de jeunes mais fait des
vannes bon et ben ça c'était en vie deux
ans tu refuses away dont face2face
définir face d'eux quelqu'un de très
bien que si elle n'était pas à ben
connaissez pas les fans de guerbet
tranquille sans vulgarité sans vulgarité
phase 1 on s'embrasse wii passe de
gâteries phase iii bene l'acta
oui c'est vrai que c'est joli phase de
basse et de la phase 2 ce qui est très
bien en plus parce que voilà et oui et
j'étais pas connu donc c'était vraiment
été sur mon charme est ce que j'ai dit 1
il n'était pas connu maintenant c'était
pas connu un van kote passe une très
bonne anecdote
merci à vous je suis sur vous parce que
même les charles moi c'est un peu mon
objectif à des lacs en c1 belle elle
sans rigoler balala le catalogue des
stations à val d'isère que la bataille
est à titi qui suit personne super qui
donne pas de noms n'ont pas changé
charles ix en lorgnant sur chamrousse
non non non
mais le premier jour quand vous arrivez
à l'école de ski et qu'il ya le tableau
pardon avec tous les profs qui sont bien
bronzé fin de saison qu'ils ont toutes
leurs photos
c'est vrai on a la chance de pouvoir
choisir mais moi j'ai fait un truc
exceptionnel comme j'étais voilà avec un
prof de ski assez bien assez connus de
la station on a profité de sa notoriété
pour utiliser les télécabines non à un
moment où il y avait personne ne connait
tous les deux et fait l'amour dans les
télécabines bath 3-3
non mais quelle loi dans la neige dans
leur écoute et moi j'ai très peu de
choses en suspens c'est pas vrai oui
mais caroline ithurbide gens rient au
nez c'est déjà une quête
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'étais reçu le sait un prix non mais
elle rigole mais attention attention
parce que elle raconte toi l'antenne
donc si vous pouvez vous voyez bien elle
a pas connu trop de mecs que ça car ou
est à placer maquillant ça veut dire
qu'elle prend le thé des cabines avec un
préservatif on n'est pas très souvent à
faire qu'à mon époque
non ils devaient avoir fait les preuves
de ce qu'ils sont tous sur eux bah vous
qui l'avez été vous savez à l'évêché rit
on va quand même si on a un bouffon va
pas le préservatif
d'ailleurs en scène français